they clamber down the canyon wall
driven by the instinct to survive
tens of thousands have made this journey
in the past few weeks
a desperate voyage made by desperate
people from the ethiopian state
of tigre
but they must cross this torrent in an
overloaded
boat if they wish to complete it
there is a constant flow of refugees now
making their way down to the river
and for many this will be the end of a
very long
journey but they've got one more
obstacle
to face the takisei river
forms a natural frontier between
ethiopia
and neighboring sudan and at least 30
000 refugees have decided to cross it
it is a momentous decision that many
have taken
in an instant
[Music]
they took our clothes our home our money
they took it all
we don't have anything we came here
naked just like this
this isolated spot filled with frenetic
activity as ethnic tigrayans flee
bombing
shelling and persecution and the
situation
may deteriorate the ethiopian prime
minister ordering the leaders of tigre
state
to surrender but few expect them to do
so
for some the experience is shattering
[Music]
i wish i could go home said this woman
it took her ten days to walk to the
river
we took a boat over to the ethiopian
side
to see whether refugees were gathering
we're in ethiopia now integra state
and uh well it's chaos here
there is a customs post and a small town
called dima
a few minutes in land and we decided to
make a short visit
we saw refugees sheltering from the sun
in dozens of homes and compounds
and sudanese military sources told us
there are thousands more on the way
they will find sanctuary in the form of
a sudanese camp
but first they must cross the takezi and
we traveled alongside them
in a leaky metal tub
[Applause]
[Music]
however everyone we spoke to said they
were willing to take the risk
for life in tigre has become unthinkable
it took 12 days to get here we lived in
a forest
a forest but now we have reached sudan
find a tent at the top of the hill where
they will collect a wristband with a
barcode
entitling them to basic provisions and a
blanket
the start of something unfamiliar many
miles from home
it's going to go on for a long time yeah
i think it will be heartbreaking
your heart's breaking okay
[Music]
they may be here for months or they
could be here for years
as a full-scale humanitarian crisis
unfolds
john sparks sky news in hamdayet eastern
sudan